ん
あの裏を合わせてみましょう行員コインなんですけども
叩きつけると意外と真上に帰ってきます
想像ね今日はドクター始めたボケもね湯で科学者のハスくれなんですよ
そんな科学者の僕もねちょっとね科学者らしくなろうと思ってみまー見てもらって
分かると思うけども僕にの壁紙は寝ない至ってシンプルの鐘楼でございます作者として
もう最悪ですね違いたティっないと思ってるて僕
今日は壁の実はまぁちょっと広告をね
やっぱり色々危ないね爆発的な実験ともすると思って壁紙は全部アルミホイールに
しようと思います
昔はちょっと安っぽいドラマで見たことあるんですよ
もしもし ever さん今動画を撮ってるんだけど声優歴3
小澤さんいつもありがとう
っていうね壁紙を全部アルミフォイルねーマッチングにしようと思いますたぶん残念性
とかってねいいと思うんだよね一多いの寒がりだからサービスはボタンで素敵なで
頑張ればいいと思ってますかっこ上げラインでかっこよければまあギンギンな部屋にし
たいもんだよ等
さてと
スウスウ
た
がなくちゃうんですねございましたでさっそく作っていきましょう
はぁ
ごちゃごちゃうるせえ yeah
くっしーよしなっています
ん
4ライトニング分野でライトニングパン屋はじめねー
冷媒 r ライディングファイヤーサージいねえ
スイート歳で焦る前で広いの前には全然でグレードファイヤー
ウェイドファイヤー
ブーブー言っにいい
great 3なぁを突破
me
これなー
結構しんどいぞ
うーん
本ん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
よし一応できましたーーー
の
ちょっとのぶちゃんはねぇ
それじゃあ目だけだとしてあげる
tar
配球でこんな感じになりましたアメリカで囲んで全文雨降りさせていただきました
科学者っぽくないですか俺はないほど部屋でしまうちょっとに行く事にするよ
3日くらいこの部屋類ことにするよ本当に何かで眩しいんすよすすめ安い
たばいばーに言いますねくさいです暖房付で内でも2なんか待ったかい気がします
たぶん気のせアルミホイルはこういう使い方もできるって言うと俺はねみんなに伝え
たかったら絶対
お母さんに内緒でしましょうじゃあなか
もう撮っていいから
おっお